this program enhancing observational
skills was started at Yale University
approximately 10 years ago and it is a
very unique collaboration between two
Yale institutions one is the Yale School
of Medicine and the other is the Yale
Center for British art it has been
imitated now by at least 20 medical
schools across the country I was running
this conference and I asked the
residents to describe their cases and
they weren't doing a very good job
I was wondering how could I get them to
do this better at that moment a painting
popped into my head as being something
that would be foreign to most of the
residents they would probably describe
everything in that object because they
didn't know what was important or
unimportant the two of us then thought
about what we could do together if
indeed we could in terms of trying to
offer a program that could enhance
medical students observational skills
and that really is the genesis of the
program we selected pictures that had a
narrative that is that there was an
implicit story within the work of art
itself and as this 19th century are
these Victorian paintings are really so
helpful for us in that they really
behave like surrogates for patients
students come in groups of 20 to the
museum there are five of us we split the
group up into groups of four we take the
four students up into the galleries I
assign my four students pre-selected
paintings as does all the other group
leaders the students are given
approximately 12 to 15 minutes to study
the painting the instructions are don't
read the label because the label
sometimes has information that we want
you to get for yourself and we want you
to study this painting
and describe it in a way that if someone
is listening but doesn't see the
painting they'll get a mental image of
it
the young man appears to have fallen
into bad peace still wearing much of his
clothes although he has draped a coat
over a chair in his room
they then spend the next 15 20 minutes
talking and describing what they see
secondly like their the way it would you
know the direction of their eyes is
completely severed from the rest of the
people in the image work and then when
you're all done then you can put that
information together into some
hypotheses or hypotheses as to what you
think this is all about something
happened to him the previous night's
yeah that caused him to perhaps read
love letter that he had kept in a chest
okay and then if you can narrow it down
by looking back into the painting but
getting collaborating information do
that and then when it's all done we will
tell you what this is about as or as
much as we know what it's about so
that's why he was put in this position
because of the notoriety associated he
was a genius who wasn't recognized after
they have given a complete visual
inventory of the painting the rest of
the group has asked if anything was left
out sometimes
interestingly enough the the elephant in
the middle of the room is not addressed
and I will say to them would you like to
say something about the person in the
middle of the painting and they're going
back and forth about what this painting
is all about in what they have seen and
what we realized and realize in the
beginning but realized afterwards we've
actually taught them something about
teamwork what it means to communicate
with one
rather over some issue in the follow-up
activity where students are given
enlarged 8 by 10 color photographs of
skin lesions they are given I think 10
of them they are timed and given a
certain amount of time with each
photograph and they need to write down
specifically what it is that they see
and after we get to about number 9 or 10
the obvious things have been said and
now they are really searching for
something different and in that search
for something different they begin to
see things they wouldn't narrowly would
have passed over okay what about his
look it's kind of like on toward the one
side well it's deviated - it is like
towards his right side right side and
there was just this wonderful kind of
togetherness in terms of their post
testing of the experience that they had
had in the galleries and this is one of
the things that really distinguishes
Yale's program is that it really centers
on increasing observational skills so
they tell the students you have two jobs
one is to recognize those signs and
symptoms that we teach you about that we
know it true but also to find new ones
that we haven't taught you about that we
don't know about so you can advance
medicine once they have this experience
then they know what it means to look for
details analyzing a painting what is
there that's all because once you do
that then you can analyze anything being
a doctor is all about seeing everything
that's in front of you and not just
seeing it but but really looking and
watching and observing and to be a
better observer is to be a better doctor
and I think the very much prude this
session very much proved that with me
today
you